Welcome to "Ear Biscuits".
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're discussing what's
it like after you put out
a series like the Lost Years series,
what has our experience been like
since sharing everything we've shared.
And now, fielding a lot of responses
and including a lot of questions
because that's what we
asked you guys to do
is tell us, use #EarBiscuits,
let us know how you're processing it
and if you have any questions for us.
So we knew we were going to do
what we were calling a follow-up
episode and this is it.
At least, this is one of them.
Yeah, I would say this is one of them.
Let's just say it's one of them.
And we may get to some questions.
But I think one of the
conversations we've been having is
as we've processed how we're,
how we're processing the reaction,
it kinda just led to the
decision to take today's episode
in a slightly different direction
but I'm not saying it
won't end up in a place
of answering questions
but we'll talk about that.
One quick thing we do wanna cover
is if you're listening to this,
you might know that the
podcast comes out every Monday
in audio form but through
the power of video,
we are also recording every single episode
with a video camera have
been for quite some time
and then the following Sunday.
So a little bit less than a week
after the podcast comes out,
the video version comes out
at youtube.com/earbiscuits.
So if you wanna see us talk
and not just hear us talk.
If you're like listening you're like,
"Man, they're referring to a photo."
Or "Man, I don't know exactly
how to take what he's saying.
"Maybe the look on his face
would help me understand it.
"Oh, he was actually
smiling when he said that."
Right.
Or "Yeah, he was crying at that point."
Well, in some people--
If you wanna see us smile and cry,
then go to the "Ear
Biscuits" channel on YouTube.
Then also made reference to
my hair during my episode
where I told my story and then--
But you're done with that.
Regretfully, I watched
a little bit of that
and it was like, "Well, it
was an interesting decision."
I'm not saying I'm not
gonna do it again but--
But we're not gonna talk about it now.
No, we're not gonna talk about it now.
Because it's not the thing we--
I'm not even gonna tell you
what my hair looks like today
because you'll have to watch it on YouTube
to figure that out.
That's not
why they're here, man.
No, well, at least 0.4%
of the listening audience
is here for my hair.
But that means that 99.6%
are here for other things,
like maybe your hair.
My hat and my jacket.
You wanna get a load of my hat and jacket.
Well, Link has on a hat and a jacket.
So, do you--
You can almost see it.
How do you wanna get into this?
Because that I do think it's,
the brief conversation we had last night--
I called you in a panic.
You called me in a panic.
No, you didn't call me in a panic
but you're like, "Hey,
we should talk about
"how we're gonna approach
this thing because."
I think that's a good place to start
because we were each individually pulling
questions and comments
that we wanted to address
or respond to.
At least that was our plan.
Yeah.
Well--
And it turns out, independently,
we were having our own,
our own struggles with how we wanted
to have this discussion today.
Right, so when I called you last night,
I had just gotten out of therapy.
He's busting out the barn doors.
I don't know if you're experienced,
those of you who go to therapy.
I mean, for me, I always go in thinking,
why am I doing this?
Like, I got nothing to say,
I got nothing to talk about.
What am I gonna do?
Just makes the,
like, I always lo myself
back into this place
where I kinda just feel
like it's unnecessary
and by the end of it,
I'm like, "This is why I go to therapy."
Well, as a side note,
this brings up something very pertinent
that I'm not gonna talk about right now
but I will talk about
later in this episode.
Continue.
Oh, well, that was a tease.
So the first thing I started talking about
was Jessie and I had had like,
basically, a fight about,
of course, we're redoing the pool area
and so this is typical
cliche married couple
construction project arguments situation.
But I kinda had this sense that
there was something going on
beneath my concern about
the construction project
that was fueling the intensity
with which I was arguing about this
and standing up for things
like where grills will be
or where grill will be.
I'm not like you, I'm
only gonna have one grill.
I'm not going two grills.
You're already losing.
But oh, it's a nice grill.
It might be one grill better
than both of your grills put together.
Well, I think--
That's at least
what I'm going for.
You were waving the white
flag at the design phase
and I'm all for it.
So, I was like, you know, I'm been feeling
like kinda tired and sort of worn out
and it isn't like, we're not--
Working hard.
Well, I will say this.
We're not working as hard
as it can get for us.
Like, we're not touring,
we don't have a major project
besides our own going things
that we're doing but I'm like,
and just usually, I would
be like have a lot of energy
but I'm like, I just feel
a little bit beat down
and I started trying to process that
and that was when I started
realizing that this,
the process of our stories going out there
and then them sort of people
interacting with them,
interacting with the
stories, interacting with us,
it's been a very
emotionally draining thing.
Now, I wanna clarify that.
It's also been awesome.
Just because it's been
emotionally draining
doesn't mean that it hasn't been great.
I mean the amount of encouragement
that we've received from people
on both ends of the spectrum
regardless of whether or not they,
people who started not being a Christian
and became a Christian,
people who were Christian
or non-Christian,
people are still a Christian,
no matter what your point of
reference is for the story,
we've received so much encouragement
and just kind messages
and thoughtful comments.
And that's been great,
hearing people's stories.
But for me, the thing that I realized
I was kinda focusing on,
this is not too surprising,
was the small percentage of people
who I kinda felt disapproved by.
Disapproved of, okay.
By them.
And, you know,
I don't wanna talk--
Not giving critical responses?
Yeah, well,
people who, I mean there's
some responses that are just
critical and not thoughtful
and those are really easy to just be like,
okay, I'm not gonna let that affect me
but there are some that are
critical and thoughtful.
And the way my personality
interacts with that
is I just have this like,
I get immediately defensive, right?
And so what I wanna do is
I wanna come on the show
and I wanna go through the
questions and the critiques
and I wanna enter into some sort of like
defense of my position.
I wanna justify the conclusions
that I've come to, right?
But maybe beyond that,
there was also people who
kind of did like a takedown,
essentially, of like my story or whatever
and my story was kinda
easier to do a takedown of
because I kind of presented
like this very specific
process that I went through
from an intellectual standpoint,
so people kind of key in on things,
be like, well, here's the
thing I took issue with here
and here's the thing I
take issue with here.
And then there were people interacting
with the people who had those
kind of critical responses
who didn't know who I was,
didn't know who you were,
didn't listen to the podcast
but immediately were interpreting me
through the lens of this
person who's being critical
and I felt, and this isn't one person,
there's a number of people have done this,
and I felt super defensive
because I felt like I was
being misrepresented, right?
And so I just realized that,
and I didn't even understand
that I was dealing with this
until I started talking it
out and just this idea of
wanting to be like,
well, this is what you,
I didn't say that or you
just said this about me
or you assumed this about my process
or you're being critical of me
and the way that I thought about this
or the resource that I suggested
and I have all these answers
that I wanna get into.
But then I very quickly
just started realizing that
I just don't want this podcast
to devolve into like a
defense of the position that we have,
the conclusions that we have come to,
for a number of reasons.
Number one--
I'm most curious about what the,
if you're gonna number them,
what are your personal
reasons because I know,
yeah, I agree that one of the reasons
is that's not what this podcast is.
Yeah, right.
Well, I'll say yes, it's
not what the podcast is.
It's like this isn't some defense of any,
this isn't a place to come
on and defend and conjecture
because that's not what
everybody's here for
but also, we're not qualified to do that.
I am not an expert in any of
the stuff that I talked about.
I'm just an interested layperson who was,
who had their faith basically turned over
by just looking in to some of these things
but I'm not then
qualified to then tell you
what you should think about it
because when I start
thinking about my process,
like it wasn't easy to
revisit a lot of those things
because sometimes, you're like,
well, in the past I was very interested
in this particular
thing and I looked it up
and I was convinced of
something but if you ask me
why were you convinced, I
can't immediately recall
why I was convinced.
A lot of times you'll become
convinced of something
but the specific reasons
you were convinced,
you're like, I gotta kinda
read that resource again
to get back to that place
because that's just the way
the human mind works, right?
Doesn't mean that I didn't
come to a conclusion
and didn't move to something else
but anyway, the idea of getting into this
like tit-for-that defending a position,
it just felt like he
would be very unhealthy
for me, personally,
but it also felt like
I was just very quickly
just kinda moving into this
place that it was about me
and it was about my ego,
which is a consistent
problem for me, right?
I mean I talked a little
bit about being a three
on the Enneagram.
And one of the weaknesses of the three
in being an achiever and a performer
is you want everyone's approval.
And so the idea of throwing
something out there,
throwing a bomb out there like we did
and being like this sacred thing
that is the most important
thing in so many people's lives
and was the most important
thing in our life,
we've discarded it for the most part,
that's throwing a rock
into a hornet's nest
and some of the hornets
will come out and sting you.
Yeah, and I just realized
that I'm not haven't been dealing
with that in a healthy way
because my response to that has been,
well, let me tell you why I'm justified.
Let me prove to you why I
was right about this thing
and it's like, no.
A, that wouldn't be effective.
It's not like that's gonna
change anybody's mind.
But B, that wouldn't be good for me.
Yeah, and I think that
as we've talked about
on this podcast and like I just said,
that's not how we've built this thing.
This podcast, and I was really glad
when you called it to hear you say that
because I didn't know why,
when I was looking back at
the questions that I was,
I was kinda stuck or
kind of troubled by it
but that helped make sense of it
that yeah, this this podcast
is a conversation between us
sharing our experiences
and our perspectives on
things with each other.
And I think, whatever
people wanna take from that
as a listener is they're free to do that
but if we start turning
towards the microphones
and the cameras and we
start saying, you know.
A little bit of that made sense.
It's like, hey, these are the resources.
If you're interested in some of the things
that either one of us talked about,
these are the books you can read
if you're interested in
that, if you're into it
but you're not gonna sit here
and go through all of
these arguments about,
okay, now, let's do a
podcast dedicated to Jesus
and all of the takeaways
from our research about that
and the conversations we've had
and let's start doing
something that's like,
that's challenging or that has an agenda
or puts out a specific
perspective that then
we're hoping to change people's minds.
I think it's more of,
I mean even when we would,
in previous episode
when we would just give
relational advice or life advice
and half the time, it would
just be for the fun of it,
we would often say, listen,
we're not experts at this.
We're just sharing our
lives and our perspectives.
Take it with caution and
sometimes, with grain of salt.
I mean we're just people.
We're friends having a conversation
that we welcome you to be a part of it
but we don't wanna be prescriptive
and we don't wanna start arguing
on a soapbox about anything.
So yeah, it started to feel like it was,
the temptation was there
to be very defensive
with some of the questions.
And yeah, because of the
nature of your story,
it generated a lot more of those questions
that weren't personal in nature
but they were intellectual in nature
or they were philosophical
or just belief-oriented.
They were they were separate
from you as a person
and it does invite those
kind of conversations
and I think having starting
to address those now
would just perpetuate that and
that's not what we're after.
Yeah.
For me, I think that I felt a lot more,
I mean you felt, you talked
about how you felt relief
and how there was a lot
of positive ripple effects
from this podcast too and you
could talk more about that
but I would say, I mean
that's predominantly
what I've experienced.
Definitely, the relief
of getting it out there
and I knew it but I
didn't fully appreciate
how sharing so much of our conversations
at this desk, at this table,
but not sharing that had kind
of really eaten away at me.
It really made me uncomfortable
to seem like I was being
real but then I wasn't being,
it wasn't like a full disclosure.
So, I think I have
experienced some lightness
associated with getting that out there.
And like you said, I
definitely did as well.
It wasn't until I started thinking about
this follow-up, which we
were like ask us questions,
make comments and respond to them
and then I just started finding myself
kind of keying in on
the critical ones or the gotcha questions.
People asking a question
because they think that by me
and trying to answer it, they're
gonna they're gonna get me
and they're gonna catch me
in some illogical thought
process, you know.
Right, whereas with my story, it was so,
it was told in a way that like
if people were critical of me,
it could have been taken
as a personal attack
of a personal experience, not
just some external assessment
of a belief about something.
Well, and I think that that's a thing
that's difficult for me is that
even though I kind of told a story
which was like these are the
things that I read or learned
that then made me question
what I had always known,
some people interacted
with the points, right?
Some people might be like
I think your conclusion here was incorrect
or I think you've given too much credence
to these critical thinkers,
people who are critical of the Bible
versus people who believe it, whatever.
But the majority of people
find some sort of fault with me, right?
Well, it was something in your process,
something in your pride,
something in the way that you see things,
you ultimately want it out,
you just didn't know it.
Like trying to find some way to explain it
based on some deficiency in me, right?
Now, first of all, you
may be right about that.
But that's kinda beside the point.
What I'm talking about right now
is it's difficult to
not take it personally
even though it's,
it's difficult for people
to not make it personal.
And I'm not saying oh, like oh--
And it was your personal process.
I think the things that you
said can be separated from you
but for you, they weren't.
Yeah, well, I wanna be clear.
I'm not complaining about this.
Like, I expected, I actually expected it
to be much worse than it was.
Like I said, the vast majority of people,
whether they're Christians are
not, have been very gracious.
I think the thing that I was reminded of
is just how big apart my ego plays
in anything that I talk about, right?
It's just like I'm obviously,
I was trying to be as honest
as I can when I tell my story
but I also kinda want to be
the hero of my own story,
don't we all?
And in telling the story,
I'm also telling it in a way
that justifies my decisions
and my conclusions.
And there's really no other
way to live life in one sense
but that can be also done
in a very unhealthy way.
We're gonna take a break here in a second
but I wanna talk about
how that tendency to
basically find personal fault with someone
who's deconstructing is
something that we relate to
really personally as well.
I'ma tell little story but before that,
there's a bunch of leashes.
We're gonna sell leashes.
We've got leashes, collars.
If you got a pet, go to mythical.com,
look at the stuff that
you can get for your pet.
Well, look at the pattern on that, Link.
I don't think we've ever had
the privilege of doing this.
Look at that.
But the pattern that is behind us
is the pattern that has made
its way onto this actual leash.
Yeah, put "Ear Biscuits" on your dog
or any other type of animal
that needs to be leashed.
There's also a collar, a
big one and a smaller one,
which Jade is currently wearing.
She's at the groomer,
she'd be in here right now.
Mythical.com, rep your pets.
Rep you boys on your pets.
In terms of my experience, I would say,
I mean I shared my story for me.
I shared,
when I reach the conclusion,
it's like I want to be hopeful,
I want to do the work to remain
engaged in a faith journey
and not just to be, not
just sit on my laurels
and go on with my day-to-day life
and there's so much that
I could get distracted by
that I would just never get back to it.
I actually feel like
sharing my story was a big,
this is a big part of my journey
because it just helped me
process things for myself
and I would say kinda jump start
or kinda reinvigorate my own process
because for a number of years,
I just kinda put it on a shelf, you know?
It's like I'm kinda stuck
and I don't, you know.
But then the thing that I started
to realize as I prepped it
and then as I shared
it, started to come out
and even afterward as I've
talked to people about it,
I've really benefited from
understanding myself even more
and I can get into,
I'd like to get into some of those details
but at the same time, at a parallel path,
the fact that again, secondarily,
it was something that resonated,
either your story or my
story or both of them
resonated with so many people
that we didn't ask people,
I don't know maybe we,
I don't think we asked for
people to share their stories,
I think we acknowledge that
it was happening along the way
but I didn't anticipate
that a lot of people
would just use it as an opportunity
to start to share their own stories
to the extent that they have and share how
they related to it, to different aspects
of what we had to say and
I was just, I would just,
I didn't know how to, I would just heart
a lot of these things
because there were so many
and I wanted to reply and say
something but, practically,
it just wasn't really possible
but I just wanted to
say that my experience
was just being blown away with
how our stories were helpful
because when you hear
somebody share something
and there were people
saying, I "don't feel alone
"now that you shared."
And, again, not just me.
They were responding to
you sometimes, me sometimes
but it just means,
it means so much that
people were moved by it,
to not feel alone, to be moved
to share their own stories
and to just to start that conversation
with their friends on the
internet and off the internet.
I was like, "Wow, I actually
think that it's helped people."
And I really didn't know
that that would happen.
Maybe it seems obvious in this
internet culture of sharing.
That's like, yeah, when you
share and when you take a risk,
it helps people but I
never associated that
with what we were considering doing.
And so, I just remember
being in my bed one night
and I was just looking
through all the stories
and I was just overwhelmed with gratitude
that it did make a difference.
And, again, I didn't know
that was gonna happen.
I don't think I would have said
I'm doing this to help people.
I think I was doing it as,
because I felt ready to do it
and I felt like it was part of my process.
So, I guess I was surprised
maybe more than you would have
thought I would have been.
Well, I mean I wanna talk about
how I interacted with all that
and like, what how that
while it was helpful,
it also increased my anxiety.
I wanna get to that
because I think there's a whole
conversation to have there
but I don't wanna skip over
the interactions that we've
had with our our old friend.
And--
Yes, I mean--
We talked we talked about him a little bit
in one of our stories, maybe your story.
I can't remember but yeah,
there's been a number of people
that we've reconnected with but
when we mentioned him,
we were talking about
how we were on the other,
we were still,
we were on the front side of it
and he was kinda going through the process
that we've described.
To recap.
So, this is a very close
friend of ours growing up
who was a fellow very strong Christian,
who, in the early 2000s, basically started
to have somewhat of a deconstruction
and we reconnected with him.
Well, first of all,
since our deconstruction,
we've connected with him and we kinda,
we know where we're each other or at
but we told him, "Hey, we're
sharing our stories publicly.
"Would love for you to
listen," or whatever.
So, that we've been kind of
talking with him since then.
He was able to uncover some
of our old correspondence
when Link and I were getting
ready to go into the ministry
to work with Campus Crusade
to do evangelism training.
And we were running some things by him
as someone who was in a different place
but then, what he was doing,
actually, we spent some time with him,
he was going back and like
writing in his journal
about the interactions
that he was having with us.
And in reading so many of
the responses to our story,
especially the responses from--
Oh, you're talking about public responses.
Yeah, yeah, so reading public
responses to our stories
and specifically, responses
from people who are,
basically, their only
response to what we said
is this is just very sad.
There's no like,
it's basically just like
I'm praying for you, guys,
this is very sad.
I hope you find the faith,
those kinds of responses.
He was a very, very reminiscent of the way
that we interacted with him
and it just reminds me how
much where we were at in life
and what we were doing was
informing our responses
because we were literally raising support
to go on staff full time.
And I had probably, you were
in the very middle of it,
I was coming to the end.
This giant sort of left turn in your life
where you've thrown, you've
left your previous job
and you're putting it
all on the line for Jesus
and then you go and you talk to a friend
who you really respect and we probably,
we had the deepest sort of
intellectual conversations
about our faith even in
high school with this guy.
We talked about things
on as deep of a level
as we could at the time
and in high school, I remember
those conversations starting.
So, we just always kinda had this
sort of philosophical
thing going with him.
And then for him to have
these really deep questions
that were kinda tearing
at the roots of our faith,
I remember me and you talking to him
and then talking to each
other and it was just like,
I think the way you
described it in a text to him
the other day was like, we just had,
there was zero openness to
what you were going through.
There was a complete inability
to turn the questions that
you were asking yourself
onto ourselves because there
was way too much at stake
at the time.
Yeah.
What are we, gonna
suddenly stop races at port
and tell everybody that who
just gave us all this money
that oh, by the way, guys,
I'm really questioning the
foundations of this whole thing.
It's like I'm not gonna go there.
So, I'm not even gonna allow
that thought to enter my mind.
Yeah, so, in my recollection
was we were as polite as we could to be
in trying to help him turn a corner,
to double back
and that was it.
'Cause that's what we were supposed to do.
So, it wasn't an actual conversation.
And he felt that and he knew that.
He was also gracious because
in his journal entry,
he basically said, "I completely get
"where these guys are coming from
"because it's where I came from."
And that's why, and so--
Yeah, I think he said that he did
to others what we were doing to him.
And so all that to say that
any sort of dismissive comments
that we're getting about our story,
which again, is a very small minority,
it's more than justified.
We deserve every bit of
it because we've done it,
we've been there and that,
and I remember thinking about him
in thinking about I was like,
"Where did you go wrong?"
Like, I think he hung out
with the wrong people.
I was trying to figure out,
I was trying to get to
the bottom of why he,
someone who had a very
real strong informed faith
was suddenly questioning it
and I was just like,
"Where did he screw up?
"Let me find that.
"Let me find where he screwed up."
I never could figure it out.
So, anyway, I just wanted
to acknowledge that,
that we've done that and we've been there.
Yeah, so, I think there are people
who are coming to our defense
when they see people say,
"It makes me sad."
And I saw someone make the point
I don't think people realize when they say
that it makes them sad
when someone else shares
their personal story
that that's manipulative.
But I get it.
I understand why it makes,
if you have a certain worldview,
and it made me sad before
for other people, so--
Yeah, 100%.
But I do think it's helpful.
I think it's helpful and
listen, I'm not saying this
but I think this could be,
this could help those of you
who have said this is sad
to understand why it's not,
it's difficult to not
take that as an insult
because if I were to say it's sad
that you that you've based your life
on something that's not true.
That's offensive, that's an insult, right?
To say that to you.
I'm not saying that but
if I were to say that,
that would be offensive,
it would be insulting,
it would be dismissive.
And so, I think the same thing is it's sad
that you guys are moving
away from this thing
that I know to be true
and it's sad that your eternal
destiny is in question.
I understand where you're coming from
and according to your worldview,
this is pretty much the only
response that you could have
but to communicate it in that way
and not understand why that's
insulting and dismissive
and people are gonna
perceive it in that way,
hopefully, I've shown a
little bit of light on that.
I think another thing
that we didn't anticipate
was that people, not that
people were gonna come out
of the woodwork in order to text or email
or try to Facebook messages
even though we're not on Facebook anymore,
about things is, well, it's
not that that surprises
but they would then reach out to our wives
or our extended families.
And so,
that was something that,
I don't know if it would have changed how
or if we would have done it
but it's not something that
we specifically anticipated.
It's like, I mean Christy
would get a bunch of messages
from people she hadn't
heard from in a while
and I know they come from a place
of really caring but it's like,
now, she's got a field
questions from people
that are like, it was
basically like, are you okay?
Are you guys, okay?
And I was like, Christy, you know,
the thing that I'm realizing is that,
when I tell the story
of us in the minivan,
like in tears, not going in a church
and trying to figure where we
were and where we each were
and all those type of things
and the anguish from that
particular story I told,
well, that was two years ago.
It's like, we're in a
different place than that.
We're not sitting,
we don't have the minivan anymore
and even if we did,
we're not sitting in it
weeping every Sunday.
We're in a much healthier,
healthy is not the right word
but like we're in a good place
and people, when you share this story
and if the last time they talked to you
was three, four, five,
six, seven years ago,
it's like, well, they don't
they don't know when that was
so it's like, did this just happen?
You know?
And really, the first
thing Christy learned
was the first question
she would ask a response
to the people that she would engage with
was have you actually
listened to the podcast?
'Cause a lot of people,
they would hear from someone
and they would have concern
but they wouldn't have
listened to it themselves.
And so that's an important point.
It's like I'm not gonna engage
if you don't really know
all the details already.
I can't sit here and retell
you all these on Facebook.
So, even from a purely
practical standpoint,
it's kinda like,
there's a handful or
maybe more than handful
of like, oh we got a...
I find myself in a
conversation with someone
and it's like they're bringing
some assumptions to the table
that like we're in trouble.
Yeah.
And that's not the case.
Yeah, I didn't anticipate,
I mean, I should have thought about it
but I was thinking about a lot of things
leading up to us talking
and I did not anticipate,
given the nature of a small town
and a community of people who,
at least in the circles that
my family runs in back home,
it's like, we're talking about
a Christian circle of people,
a very well-connected group of people.
Both my family and Jessie's family.
So it's like the amount of people
who have kinda come up
to them saying things,
making assumptions, again,
having not listened to
the podcast in many cases.
Yeah, I feel like I could
have prepared them better.
I feel bad about that.
I think that's been a source
of some anxiety for me as well
as I've thought about this
because they knew that we
were gonna talk about it
to some degree.
Some more than others.
They're back there on
kind of the frontlines.
It's like we've been dealing
with a lot of the online stuff.
Nobody comes up
to us on the street.
But nobody in LA.
Yeah.
But they'll see somebody
at the grocery store.
You're not sitting on a
restaurant and a grocery store
and somebody's gonna come up to, you know.
Yeah, so, I guess we could
have done better on that front.
But I wanted to talk
about what you were saying
with the number of,
the way that I interacted with the number
of like stories that people were telling
and a number of people who related.
Now, my initial reaction
was one, this is awesome,
this is super encouraging.
Like you said, there's a few times
where I was just reading people's stories,
it was very emotionally,
it's a very emotional thing.
It's like people have been
through some shit, man.
Yeah.
In contrast to our stories.
Like I said, it was very difficult
to kinda move out of that world
but that world we benefited
personally from that world
in a lot of ways that other
people have a lot more trauma
depending on their background.
And some of those stories
are just heart-wrenching.
But the way that again, so there's,
Just sort of my heart reaction to it
which is this is great and
then there's my head reaction
to it which is like what
are we gonna do with this?
I'm always thinking about
what the next thing is
that we're gonna do and--
Yeah, I thought about that too.
When you got all these
people sharing this story
and there feels like there's this momentum
and there feels like there is this,
we've all kind of left something
that was very organized and
was a very particular movement
into this thing that it's
just pretty nebulous,
what is this life after Christian faith.
Yeah, are you talking about thoughts
that enter your mind like,
well, should we organize something?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I wanna be clear, I wanna be clear.
I'm too old and just wise enough
to know that that would
be a horrible idea.
I'm not talking about a Rhett Link church.
I'm talking about like a specific, like,
oh, let's complexion of this podcast
to have some programmatic
addressing of some of these things.
I would say in a more general sense,
it's just asking the question
of is there a project
associated with this, right?
Mm-hm.
That's one question that enters my mind,
is like is there a project?
I don't know what that is
but you got all these people,
they've got their stories,
there's this momentum,
we've tapped into something
and so I feel this pressure
to sort of figure that out.
At the same time, I'm
feeling this pressure
to like you said, this has sort
of been a kick in the pants
to like sort of re-engage spiritually.
For me, that's been true but it's also,
kinda the way that it's
registered with me is
I threw out this deconstruction story
and talked about what I
don't believe anymore.
I talked a little bit
about what I do believe now
but what I do believe now is held
with a much lower level
of conviction and passion.
Because it's more of a position
of openness and curiosity
but I don't wanna be in
that position perpetually
and never embrace anything, right?
But there was this sort of
like, people like, you just,
again, you just threw this
rock into the hornet's nest
and now, you got these
hornets flying around
and some of them are coming up to you
and asking, well, what now?
You know?
Mm-hm.
And I'm not trying to put on the mantle
of some spiritual leader.
That's the last thing that I
want to do because that's not,
it's very much the last
thing that I ever want to do.
But there is this part
of me that's just like,
well, you should find some answers.
You should find some answers
and then you should relay those answers.
And again, I just feel like
that is rooted in my ego.
I don't think that that's
rooted in anything good.
I don't think that there's,
I think it's very much about a personal,
personal interest and
personal self-justification.
I don't think that there's any,
I should be leaning into that.
That doesn't mean that I
shouldn't be personally seeking
and being open and being open
to whatever is next for me,
which I think that I am
but doing that because I
want to then present myself
to a group of people
who are listening is a,
and the interesting thing is--
It's a trap.
Ironically, that's what
ministry is for so many people.
That's what any position of leadership is
but I've got a lot of
friends who are pastors
and I've had a lot of
and some of them in
their most honest moments
have relayed to me
that there is this sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy.
I don't know, that's probably
not the right terminology
but there is this idea that now,
I am the one that you
are coming to for answers
and so I must create the answers.
I must have the answers.
I must live the life.
I must have the appearance
of having it figured out
because that is what you expect of me
and I think that a lot of pastors
are just kinda stuck in this--
It's tough.
Hamster wheel of appearances and kinda,
and the church, in a lot of ways,
has set it up that you can't screw up.
You can't be a human.
You can't have imperfections
especially if you're in leadership,
especially if you're the pastor.
Right.
Yeah, I feel for them.
But I'll draw an
analogous scenario for us.
I was on a Valentine's date
with Christy and first of all,
there's a story that
I'm not gonna tell now.
Maybe I'll tell it next
week when it's like,
when we have more space for
this so don't let me forget.
I got this funny thing that happened.
But that's kind of my point.
I was in a dinner and
another weird thing happened
that I'm not referring to,
and I made a joke to Christy at dinner
and I was like, "Oh, you know I'm going
to talk about this on 'Ear Biscuits'."
And it was like,
she was like, "Uh-uh, are you serious?"
It's like, and it wasn't
that she didn't want me
to share a funny story.
It's just that we're on a date.
This is about me and her
and if I'm sitting there,
the moment something happens,
I'm like, "Oh, yeah, I got
a 'Ear Biscuit' story."
Then that robs the intimacy of the moment.
It's like, well, we just had
a funny moment, you know?
We experienced a funny moment
that you can then have
on an audience later.
And I was like, actually,
I was just joking
because I that was my joke, Christy,
well, that was my defense.
It's just a joke
but I'm talking about it on
"Ear Biscuits" right now.
No, I'm talking about--
Talking about.
Talking about it but I'm
not talking about it.
Okay.
But maybe next week,
I'll share another story
but not this one because
it's off limits now.
Because that's a sacred, precious.
Just between you and Christy.
But my point,
I hear your point when it comes to like,
am I gonna pursue?
Am I gonna like, let's just
say it's find an answer
to a specific spiritual
philosophical question for yourself.
Are you gonna find that question
just so you can turn around
and prove that you have an
answer on "Ear Biscuits"?
Like that's dangerous, that is a trap.
You know, it's like--
It's a trap for certain personalities.
My personality, listen, it's a trap for me
and it's one of the ways
that I interacted with responsibilities
in the church, right?
It's like, yeah, of course,
I'm gonna lead a Bible study, right?
And, of course, every once in a while,
if they asked me, I'll preach.
Give a talk on something.
And I think there's a,
ironically,
the way and, of course,
our experiences with
the evangelical church
but the way the evangelical church
is structured at this
point is typically men
who are Type A personalities,
who would otherwise make great
CEOs make really good pastors
in the system that is currently set up.
And they're charismatic leaders,
not charismatic in the theological sense
but just winning personalities.
They're smart, they're insightful,
they know how to relate, they
know how to tell a good story.
And they quickly find hundreds,
if not thousands of people who want in
and I think it just
creates a really unhealthy,
I know for me, personally, if
we had a stayed in ministry,
I'm sure that we would have
taken some sort of path
in leadership and I think I operated
in a really unhealthy place
for a really long time.
I know I did, I described it.
A as a worship leader.
Yeah, but the interesting thing
is that to get back to
the what we're gonna do
with this momentum or whatever it is,
and this is kinda what I was talking about
in therapy last night is finding a way
to just lean in to the
personal nature of the process.
But it not being about a movement.
It not being about
being right, being justified,
being the Bible answer man.
You know what I'm saying?
And having an answer and
having a reason for everything
because very quickly, almost immediately,
that just becomes about me.
It just becomes about me
wanting to justify myself
and to get your approval.
The whole process that I've
been going through in therapy
is leaning away from that
and being like it's not,
no, no, no, it's not
about people's approval.
It's not about what
people think about you.
It's about figuring out
what is actually happening
in your heart.
So, so my desire for when
we talk about these things
on the podcast is just it to,
I'm not saying we shouldn't
answer a question or two,
at some point, even now, I don't know,
probably not now, we're
almost out of time but
I want the tone of that and
the purpose of that to be,
hey, I'm not an expert,
just a couple of guys
trying to figure out life,
trying to move closer to
the truth, doing our best.
Yeah, for me, like I said,
the process of share my
story really helped me,
almost internalize some conclusions
about like realizing
things about who I was
and about how I interact.
Like, the way that I
interacted with my faith
and my belief system and
what that meant about me
as a person then, what it means for me now
and, well, there's one tweet from Holly
that I wanted to read.
She said, "I, too, was raised evangelical
"and I'm an Enneagram one," like me.
"I struggled my whole life trying to be a,
"quote, better Christian, and
it wasn't until after college
"that I realized I was exhausted
"from living with this internal struggle."
This process of putting this
out there has really helped me
begin to understand to a new
level my own internal struggle
and that there is absolutely
a level of exhaustion
that I did not know that
was there associated with
my perfectionism, my underlying anxiety.
And again, I know that
there's a lot of anxiety there
and I and it's not all from my
experience within the church.
It's from a lot of things.
And so, it really provided
the occasion for me
to say, you know what, I
am going to go to therapy.
I'm not just gonna talk about it.
We've talked about it a lot.
Christy and I have talked about it a lot.
Some of our closest friends,
we've talked about it for years
and it almost felt like I was
practically going to therapy.
But that's also--
But that's so wrong.
No, that's so Link.
Yeah.
You have this, and I can't come up
of maybe other examples.
I was like, I'm not opposed
to it, I just--
But you have this
tendency that I've noticed
throughout our lives together that like,
sometimes, just like when
somebody close to you
kinda starts doing something
or is interested in something,
you're just like, yeah, yeah,
I'm, by proxy, interested.
I am, by proxy.
So, I think you've been
experiencing the benefits of therapy
because the people you're
closest with have been going.
You pick up on a lot.
Right.
And it's not like we
don't read and discuss
a lot of the same books.
But last night, ironically,
the same time you were at therapy,
I was at my first therapy appointment
and I don't think without
going through this process,
I would have pulled the trigger
on setting up that appointment.
A first therapy,
I'm gonna sit here and give
you a play-by-play but,
one hour is not a lot when
you're trying to get it
and when you have as much as I have
that you're trying to get out.
But I'm very excited
to have taken that step
and to me, it's a tangible
step for me, personally,
as a result of,
to follow through on the
commitment that I made to myself
and just share it at the
end of my story that was,
I do wanna work at understanding
and loving myself more
and explaining my capacity
to love others more
and also to pursue faith.
To me, those things are connected.
I don't think if I can't
start to love myself more,
I don't know if I can
receive any love from God,
if that love is there to
be received, you know?
So,
again, I'm just getting
started but I'm very,
I'm excited.
I know there's a lot of
pain associated with therapy
and I also know that I have a lot of,
that there's this fear
that's somewhere in me that
then, on the underside of that,
there's things that I've
been afraid to explore.
But my hope and my excitement
to grow and to work at it
overrides the fear
that I think that maybe
has always been there.
And I think this process
has helped me realize.
So.
And again, to hear,
like Holly's tweet that
like she related to that,
it was just hearing that somebody related,
then kinda doubled back on itself
and helped me understand
myself even better,
hearing it in somebody else's words.
It's like, well, this is how I feel
and this is the words
that I would put it in
of being exhausted.
It's like, wow, yeah, that is me.
So it's already come back
and I just feel,
I'm grateful that we've done it.
Just for me, personally.
I cannot own how other
people process it for them,
that's on them.
Well, if we are gonna answer a question,
I think you're kinda getting
very close to it already.
A question that I saw a
number of times was why,
why tell this story?
It may be even more specifically,
there were people who were
like why tell this story?
What if you're wrong?
What if you're wrong and you're leading
an untold number of people,
depending on the
popularity of this podcast,
down the wrong path?
Do you really want that?
Do you really want that on your shoulders?
You wanna be responsible for that?
I think that most of those comments
are coming from people
who haven't been listening
to the podcast and I don't
just mean the episodes,
I mean the podcast as a whole.
Yeah.
Because I think that
anyone who's been on board
for any length of time has
sort of seen this coming
because we have gotten
increasingly personal
and so listen, some people are
like, I would never do that,
I would never talk about what
is happening to me in therapy
and have thousands of people listen to it.
Listen, I get that, I respect that.
And I don't exactly
know why this is the way
that we've chosen to do what we're doing.
In some ways,
this podcast has become therapy,
it has become very therapeutic, right?
Because we talk about,
I talked to my therapist in the way
that I talked to you guys, on here, right?
It's just very much like,
you kinda just start talking
and see what happens.
And I don't know if there's
just this increased desire
for vulnerability and being
able to just communicate that
with a wider audience, I don't
know what the motivations are
and I don't know exactly how we got here.
I just know that, like you said,
the idea of continuing to
kinda pull back the curtain
and be like this is just
two guys trying to live life
and figure it out and if you
wanna be on the conversation,
listen in on the conversation of two guys
who've known each other
forever, who are best friends,
who work together, who
are husbands and fathers
and now, people who've deconstructed
from their former Christian faith.
You wanna be along for the ride,
then let's do it, let's do it together.
But because it had gotten,
the tone had gotten so
vulnerable and there was so
much about self-disclosure
and because it was so
related to our careers,
like we can't honestly talk about
why we do what we do as an actual career
without talking about how we got here
and telling the full story
and we honestly can't tell the full story
without putting our
perspective on those years
into perspective, which then requires us
to tell our story, personally.
It all kinda fit together.
But I think another answer
is that we are discovering
that when you are vulnerable,
it opens you up to more
love and more empathy,
for, again, for yourself
and for your best friend
and for other people.
What I just described it like,
I share my story for me,
it helped other people and
then that response helped me.
It's just the way,
people look at it like a show
and yes, we have to set
boundaries for ourselves
and we have to be like the thing
we talked about a few minutes ago,
about like whether it's on the date
or like our version of
being the preacher but,
so yeah, we have to be protective
and we have to set boundaries
and we're gonna learn that as we go
but we're able to,
and I'm grateful that we're able
to have an honest conversation
in front of a microphone
that we would have if it wasn't here.
We've talked about how
we have them a lot more
because they're here than if
the microphone is not here
but then we also,
what I'm saying is we're
conducting an honest friendship.
It just happens to be
recorded and I'm just,
what people do with it is their business
but I we also experience
a greater capacity
for connection with,
and love with an audience
because it's not just some people sitting
in chairs listening,
it's individual people
who were then contributing
to a conversation.
It's not like we're going on television.
It's a different thing, you know?
And the nature of the
conversation has been
really refreshing.
And I wanna read this one thing.
On the Discord channel
of the Mythical Society,
which is, if you don't
know, that's our fan club
and yes, you gotta pay for
it, I'm not promoting it
but I'm just saying it like,
I was just so encouraged
by this one exchange
and I'm not gonna read the whole thing
but there was this
16-year-old guy who was,
he was processing our "Ear Biscuits"
and he just shared that
he's had a devout set of beliefs,
the specifics of which aren't pertinent,
and that he was impacted
by our conversation
and there was parts of it
that kinda shook him up
and he was just sharing that,
not with us but just in the Discord.
And then a response from one
particular mythical beast,
I just wanna read part of it.
Well, I'll read the whole thing.
"I remember being there as a teenager
"so I definitely know
what you're going through.
"My best advice is just to trust yourself
"and to remember that
there's nothing wrong
"with questioning and
researching on your own
"and coming to your own conclusions.
"Remember that no matter
what your religion teaches,
"there is nothing wrong with
questioning or having doubts
"and that whatever conclusions you come to
"or choices that you make,
"make sure that you're
making them for yourself
"and no one else.
"You may have people try to guilt you
"into making a certain decision
or believe in a certain way
"because they want you to
believe the way they do.
"I know I definitely did but ultimately,
"no one but you can
decide what you believe."
And then the response was,
"Yeah, that's what I need to hold on to."
And then there was some more there.
And it says, "If you need support,
"I know there are a ton
of people in this server
"who would be happy to talk or listen
"and if there's anything in particular
"you're struggling with,
"we might be able to provide resources."
"Again, I really appreciate
it," was the response.
And I think there are a
couple of things there.
It just seems like that's the message
that I talk to my kids about, you know?
And it is such a big deal to say okay,
you have to make these
decisions for yourself.
No one can make these decisions for you.
They can but you really need
to make these decisions for yourself,
no matter what it is, you're
gonna be loved and supported
by this community,
which is my second point
that I've just blown away
that that one example
is repeated again and again that there's
so many people in our community
and then it gives me hope
for humanity at large
that there's that level of love
and support for people that,
even if you're not talking
about the specifics
of what do I agree with you on this
or are we on the same
page or are you right
or are you wrong?
But it's love and
support and encouragement
to deal with those things in
the most healthy way possible.
These issues that are so important.
And I was just grateful for that.
And that's why we don't,
we don't want the conversation to devolve
into an argument, right?
Yeah.
About the finer points of theology.
And again it's not that I don't think,
I just wanna be just really clear.
It's not that we don't
think that you having
your own answers
as close to the truth as
possible is not important.
As I hope, I demonstrated in my story,
it's like because those
answers are important
is why I don't believe like
I used to believe, right?
It isn't that those theological points
and examining those
things are not important,
they're very important but
the moment that they become
a source of contention between people
and the moment that you take
love out of your interaction,
you're missing the point,
regardless of what side
of the issue you're on.
I think that just the idea,
because basically, what
you're talking about
is that the most, and
this is a cliche and corny
but the most important
thing is love, right?
It's like what is my ethic
or what are my ethics at this point?
It's love.
and I actually think
that asking that question
in any given situation, what
is the most loving response?
What is the most loving way
forward in this situation
is a pretty good guide.
And incidentally, that's very consistent
with what Jesus taught, you know?
Faith, hope and love, the
greatest of these is love.
I think that regardless of where you're at
and where you come down
on these particular issues
and what you think
about the nature of life
and the nature of eternity,
you're not gonna go wrong if
you kinda fall back on that.
What is the most loving
thing that I could do
in this situation?
And like Link said, I think
that it's been super encouraging
that the vast majority of the conversation
has been loving and respectful.
We have an incredible
community, we value that a lot
and that's the conversation
that loving conversation
is what we want to continue to engender.
And it's not about two guys who are,
listen, we may have engineering
degrees but we're just,
we're YouTube comedians.
That's what we are.
We're not authorities
on any of these issues.
If you're coming to either one of us
to figure out what you
think about your faith,
there are much better sources.
And so, that was that was
not the intention at all
in telling our stories
was you to be convinced,
that we were right.
It's just very much hey,
this is what our process was,
this is what our story was.
You should be doing
your own investigation.
But we just wanna be about love.
It's that simple.
And on that note, can I
recommend a children's book?
Sure.
I was reading this book to Lando.
He pulled it off his shelf
and this is my Recs in Effect this week.
It's called the "The Three Questions"
written and illustrated by
Jon, J-O-N, J. Muth, M-U-T-H.
"The Three Questions" is based
on a story by Leo Tolstoy,
it's a short story that I had never read.
And so as I was reading this
children's book to Lando,
I was just moved.
And it's very pertinent
to the conversations
that we've been having
and it was just like,
it felt like a faith moment,
I'll be honest that I was,
I mean like Lando started
looking at me weird
because I was like
tearing up and I was like,
"This book, this is amazing."
There's some wisdom in this
and I didn't realize that it was based
on a Leo Tolstoy a short story
until we were done reading it
but like I could sense
that there was some depth to this thing.
So, you know what, I'm not
gonna tell you about it
but I recommend, if you,
Lando's nine, he was very much into it
but you don't have to
have kids to read it.
I actually recommend this
children's book adaptation
instead of just listening to on Audible
or reading the Leo Tolstoy
short story of the same name,
though I do recommend that story as well
but the way that it's
turned, is more modernized
and it's a little bit more existential is,
it's very powerful.
So, that's my recommendation.
Will you read it to me?
A kid's book.
Will you come over to my
house to read it to me
and tuck me in tonight?
Gladly, yeah.
Good.
Yeah.
#EarBiscuits, let's
continue the conversation.
And listen, we're gonna
answer some questions
at some point, so I don't
want everybody to think
we've just completely thrown
all your questions aside.
We've still got a bunch of them.
We'll get back to them.
We're just trying to zero in on the tone
of how we're gonna approach those.
Thanks for listening.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.